[Aplausos]
a minha vida é observar
dado e tentar transmitir lá e ao longo
destes meus anjos do repórter do globo
conta que a realidade tem muitas facetas
tem variadas facetas e o primeiro era
digamos assim a grande aventura da minha
parte é tentar considerar os aspectos
todos do real o que é verdadeiramente um
edifício e no que se refere à a
experiência que teve recentemente com o
encontro com algumas mulheres finas
ainda mais fascinante se torna de mim
esta aventura de abraçar a realidade
segundo a totalidade dos seus fatores
porque nós damos conta de que há sempre
uma limitação da nossa parte porque a
realidade é essa tal maneira
[Música]
multifacetada que a nossa tendência é
encararmos a realidade muitas vezes a
forma como convém mas isso é normal e
sobretudo na idade jovem acontece muitas
vezes as duas mulheres que eu conheci e
que estou muito grata a tua experiência
que transmitiram uma chama se maria de
fátima outro olívia e as que serão 10
sempre inseridas no mundo da pesca no
mundo do mar são amigas e moram na mesma
rua e contaram que viram um anão promar
do outro pra igreja tanto testemunhando
que recorda as vaias oo a relação
profunda com o mar ea fé e comunhão
tamanho que cacheiro vim num contexto
familiar normal respeitando muito
marginal de gradualmente à medida que se
dê conta da realidade muitas vezes é
superior aos nossos sonhos é bom
arriscar é bond já a nossa tendência
neste percurso que o curso primeiramente
eu acho que todos que é tentar que a
realidade vai ao encontro dos nossos 10
só que é e começava em acompanhando o
papa de perto uma das 12 linhas o papa
francis
de resto também participou num terno
como sabem vendo encarecidamente para
construirmos pontos e por isso também é
um grande incentivo para esta noite uma
uma das jovens alertas do papa francis
que exatamente realidade é superior à
idéia
nós muitas vezes partimos pra vida pra
ir pro início de vida sobretudo o
governo na maneira de encarar a
realidade com uma idéia ea realidade de
monta essa idéia e isso aconteça por
influência nestas terras
nesta realidade e sobretudo na regata
chinês ea maioria do fato e mail lívia
com qualquer falar e testemunham isso
uma maneira impressionante porque a
maria fátima perdeu marido frágil e
atrasar os iam livia perdeu de uma só
vez um filho e três irmãos ea maneira
como contam esta esta facto não é vencer
é a tragédia de vida delas não cancela o
sofrimento na mão até de contar e
sobretudo o livro foi a 32 anos e mesmo
assim observa que conta com nó na
garganta
o que me impressionou foi que não
ficaram esmagadas pela realidade pelas
circunstâncias do real e confrontadas
com isso eu perguntei nos olham pro mar
agora como ainda ouvimos um testemunho
desta noite como de facto a estas
respeita ao mesmo tempo este tumor
apesar da consciência de que ou só
ouviram as ondas do mar assim também me
encantava olívia angustiava só de pensar
que nem teria sido o sofrimento dos seus
créditos no seu filho dos seus irmãos
contando com uma serenidade e
pressionante e eu perguntar isso porque
se o marlos tem inovado ao mar iso e
outra o filhos irmãos porque elas tinham
aquela tranquilidade e e aí também
argumento pra umas pra uma experiência
que eu testemunhei muitos pontos do
mundo não é só aqui e felizmente assim
muitas vezes anonimamente não é não
aparecem nas primeiras páginas dos
jornais mas o testemunho passa por esta
certeza de que há uma realidade que os
crimes supera e que a amiga
apesar a apesar de surpresa e nunca
células sofrimento não é não cancela as
agruras da vida sempre haverá mais
casamento por uma coisa melhorou e ver o
que é das duas a mais velha
isto é mesmo esta consciência que desde
sempre ela percebeu que a vida nos é
dada e contava que o percebeu por
exemplo observar as formigas a pensar
como é que a agitação do bebê
o olhar pra trás flores plano traz
leveza de uma flor
esta mulher que as finas de meu olho eu
eu mesmo pra a variedade dos países
dentro do mar só pode ser alguém que nos
ama muito e então ruga entre jogada o
fato mas vocês salvem também renovou o
seu o seu filho e os seus irmãos e ela
tanto ela como a maria de fátima silva
responderam mas as coisas são usadas
somos emprestado não são nossas portanto
tornou as coisas e as pessoas e as
relações e esta é esta familiaridade com
uma dimensão maior armas muito problema
selvage cm que nós precisamos controlar
as coisas e confrontar quando nos
confrontamos com pessoas assim
isso é muito provocador neste contexto
de jornalista foi apresentada por
exemplo testemunhar de histórias
pessoais em casos concretos
das mulheres dos cassinos destas duas
vias para tantas outras também como eu
vimos esta noite nos testemunhos por
exemplo na colômbia
ainda agora recentemente numa viagem que
o papa francisco fez elkis mesmo com
esta em impulso ideal permanente de
criar pontos nos ajudar a perceber que o
outro é um bem e que a diferença é um
bem que incentivou encontro de vítimas
da guerrilha
tanto os que eram mulheres e que se
arrependeram ea juiz foram vítimas da
guerrilha na colômbia seja cerca de um
milhão de vítimas neste momento terrível
com feridas abertas ainda e houve uma
senhora uma mulher que testemunhou
aquele guerreiro ele tenha assassinado o
pai o marido raptado uma filha que
acabou também por ser morta e um filho
mais novo um filho mais novo dela que
ela tem acabamento raro sempre tudo
vítimas destas com conflitos no interior
da colômbia e encontrou um jovem ferido
quando regressava a casa depois do do
filho mais novo teve a coragem de levar
pra casa pra tratar de um dos jovens e
deitou colocou no quarto do filho morto
tanto o que ela não sabia quem era
quando melhorou tratado por ela olhou a
volta do quarto e viu as fotografias do
filho e quando eu fiz parte do grupo no
bando que seu filho do papa que deu
graças a deus porque com uma grande
jogada pelo papa porque era isso porque
ela quer que ela tenha tido que um gesto
que ela era grata
a resposta certo modo vai ao encontro do
que do que me disseram neste encontro da
15 dias é olívia maria de fátima na é
que só pode haver alguém que nos ama
demoradamente a certa altura já não me
lembro será maria de fátima será o livro
ensina que deus é maravilhoso e eu
perguntei mas mesmo através destes e
perfis de sofrimento sim só pode haver
um desígnio grande e é minha a minha
refeição também ajuda também é partir da
experiência né dos testemunhos a pensar
que há sempre alguma coisa maior que nos
ajudar a ser mais humanos
apesar e que não cancela sofrimentos
também em uma outra região nas filipinas
totalmente devastada por um ciclo anual
dias podemos ter certamente ainda não
teve tempo como este
já nas filipinas também não encontrou
semelhante em que o papa quis ir mesmo a
zona mais devastada
aí foi do lado do papa francisco que
planta e que o sofrimento tanta gente
significa que está em casa ou mutilada
por causa das enxurradas e daquelas
cinco anos com ventos fortíssimos o
pessoal gente repente morreu tudo da sua
família que estavam sozinhas
o papa já tinha feito um discurso
preparado um discurso em roma que não
tenha sido distribuída nós e quando
chegou lá e se encontrou com uma ideia
do roma bonita muito bonita quer esse
discurso preparado mas quando quando
achou esse confronto com a realidade
quer aquela gente eu sempre disse que
gosta a realidade é superior a ideia é
realidade fez com que eu 0 lado o
discurso e disse mesmo tenha trazido
romão discurso vamos fazer mas agora
estou aqui com você ouvirá chovia
moderadamente nesse de renda por cima
eu estou aqui convosco e eu não tenho
nada para dizer só celesio
esse é uma faceta que o papa gosta muito
por causa desta assim também constrói
pontos porque é de coração a coração
também falava junto aqui hoje muito
nisso esta á a a esta capacidade de
enfrentar a realidade sem ser
superficial mental sem ser imediata por
cercar a lenda de uma aparência imediata
dar mais um passo para aprofundar o que
verdadeiramente interessa e naquele
momento concreto o papa francisco dentro
daquela era praticamente um milhão de
pessoas que estava além fez silêncio e
dirceu negou essa pena dele e devemos
também é o dom das lágrimas ou seja e
com isso termino a coisa que mais me
ajudará a vinha que mais me fascina
nestes encontros improváveis diria
porque são realidades que a pessoa muito
em como elas existem e que nós nos
sentimos desarmados muitas vezes sem
resposta
o nosso coração para sempre mais e às
vezes circunstâncias parece que vão no
sentido contrário e violenta não é como
foi o caso desta mulher do concreto
estou aqui a falar convosco é livre e
maria de fátima mas elas não cancelar ou
dos raios que caem e arriscam a e sempre
mais
é este coração que não se renda com as
dificuldades que circunstâncias nos
trazem também não cancela estes as mais
a vida traz uma experiência de limitação
certo modo não é
nós jogamos o a plenitude mas depois
somos limitados e nesse sentido a estas
pessoas estas histórias pessoais
a maria fátima lívia a própria estas
pessoas que o que o papa francis comidas
desvalorize chamar a atenção que são
daquelas às vezes mais nas periferias
os mesmos protagonistas são fundamentais
e suscita em nós uma atratividade e uma
certeza inabalável que é um outro maior
do que eu vou fazer minha mas eu e essa
serenidade identificar é absolutamento
quero olhar e nessa medida não lívia
carla maria de fátima que nem tantos
outros
e também tem a certeza que todos os que
a questão poderão identificar tantos que
são assim que vivem em certos grandes
coisas e esse vivem uma misteriosa
notícia apesar das dificuldades da vida
e nesse sentido creio que devemos
concluir também com que dizia uma poeta
brasileiro quem gosta muito dela prazo e
que acha que se adapta muito bem esta
com esta realidade é que os rios
sobretudo tendo os olhos fixos nas
meias-finas que é produzir do meu
coração o mar inteiro é uma gota
[Aplausos]